at this point you might have some
questions you might be wondering if git
pull is the same as fetching and then
merging why haven't our previous polls
generated merge commits like this one
did it's a fair question the answer is
fast forward merges this kind of merge
occurs when you merge two commits where
one is an ancestor of the other that is
where one commit is reachable by the
other if all merges happens the way
we've been showing you so far if you
took B and tried to merge it into a then
you would end up with a merge commit
that had both commits as a parent and
you would move a in the usual case merge
commits are generated to keep track of
all the commits that played a part in
getting to this new state but in this
case the commits that played those parts
are this one and this one and this
commit already has all the information
about this one's history so there's no
actual reason to add this extra one so
instead of adding a new commit all we
would do is update the label to point
here instead hopefully at this point the
named fast-forward merge makes sense
we're taking a label from the history of
a branch somewhere in its ancestry and
moving that label forward to the tip of
the branch take a look at these commit
histories check the box next to each
diagram we're merging branch B into
branch a would result in a fast-forward
merge